Joey Kaufmann USC beat writer at the
Orange County Register in New York or LA
Daily News I should say joins us now to
talk about USC in particular you're in
Hollywood
Joey scriptwriters can't do this can
they I mean this is you know above and
beyond the call of duty yeah it almost
reads kind of like on that new Netflix
show or something that's pretty wild
it's got Hollywood USC it's sort of
American privilege in the 21st century
it's got everything you'd want how would
you sum this up if somebody is just
finding out about this now kind of the
way you touched on but it's really for
you it from the USC perspective it's
it's it's a story that's another scandal
for the university it's another federal
investigation this was two years after
the school at a men's basketball
assistant coach who was implicated in
that FBI corruption case and and that's
kind of the issue for USC is that they
can't really stay out of their own way
it's another black guy for the athletic
department how high up does this go like
if we felt the entire fallout from USC
one of the interesting parts a lot of
the schools had a coach involvement
Texas had a tennis coach was involved in
it
yeah a lot of coaches uses the clip
previously mentioned UCLA had its men's
soccer coach USC had some coaches
involvement their legendary water polo
coach who was fired yesterday Yohan
Bhavik a former women's soccer coach but
they also had a senior associate
athletic director Donna heinel involved
in it and for people who aren't familiar
with her she was she's basically kind of
a third ranking member of the athletic
department there's Lynn Swann the
athletic director Steve Lopes the CFO
even Donna hi know who's also the senior
woman's administrator so she's
overseeing all the women's sports at USC
she heard role at the University is also
kind of a planning person with the
athletic department going to the
admissions department so she had a
pretty powerful role and if you're kind
of looking to have Biscay go on for a
long period of time she would be kind of
the right person to go after because she
was a person as the diamond talks about
she would meet with the subcommittee in
the admissions department every two
weeks present
so if you're looking to slip somebody's
application in under the radar and
that's doctored in some form she's the
person to go to if you're the FBI how
deep do you go how long is this scheme
been going on at schools like USC
according to the complaint it began in
2014 they said Donna heinel took more
than 1.3 million dollars and bribe
payments for more than for two dozen
prospective students who were posing as
athletes so it's gone on now for that's
six years why did you write why did you
they have to create profiles of fake
athlete yes some of this was not really
brilliant work I mean the degrees to
which they went to some of this was they
went a good ways they would have they
had a Lori Loughlin had two daughters
who had no previous crew experience they
don't have any background in the sport
and they basic photo zuv her two
daughters on a on a rowing machine so it
wasn't exactly really all that elaborate
they had a it was a private executive
private equity executive son in the Bay
Area who went to a high school that
didn't even have a football team so they
made him into a fake kicker punter I
suppose you wouldn't need actually plan
on he maybe to be a faker punter so they
took some photos of him and use
Photoshop to present him to the
admissions board as a punter and he got
in as a walk-on so they kind of had to
do some of this stuff with photoshopping
it's not to elaborate but I guess it was
elaborate enough to get by how'd they
break the case they a lot of this was
obtained via wiretaps one of the the key
people involved was William singer he's
run the Newport Beach charity and and he
was flipped and he was caught on some
wiretap talking and some of his phone
conversations were intercepted so that
was a big part of it in relation to USC
he seemed talking to somebody
administrators and some of the families
talking about Donna heinel and the
administrators so that's kind of how
some of the USD information came to
light so you're gonna be jail time
Donna heinel was arrested yesterday and
so with Johan bavitz the water polo
coach that kind of Mane's to be seen but
there they were taken into custody
yesterday and they're gonna dive in and
I guess we'll see from here Wow imagine
showing up at work and you're planning
your day and then all of a sudden
there's a knock at the door yeah we're
here to see Miss heinel oh yes come on
in who can I say is calling the FBI Oh
Oh hold on and next thing you know
you're interlocking your hands and
you're headed to jail I mean this is a
this is a movie waiting to happen Joey
you don't even need a writers script it
they've already done it crazy and this
is the second Johan vomits was with the
water polo team and arrested while they
were there preparing to play Hawaii
later this weekend so they were in
Honolulu it's kind of a second time and
in two years we're USC coaches out on
the road either with the team recruiting
Tony Blaine was amended basketball
assistant coach he was arrested two
years ago at his hotel room in Tampa
Florida while visiting the recruit so it
did everything that's happened the last
couple of years has been kind of wild
from the federal government's
involvement in the basketball case and
then now that is it over as far as you
want city the fallout who knows it seems
like there's a new scandal every day the
u.s. even it's hard to predict what
happens next so I don't want to be
proven wrong or or anything like that
all right
well Joey thank you for your time we
appreciate it okay thank you two rare me
damn that's a Joey Kaufman UNC beat
reporter the Orange County Register and
the LA Daily News for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]